all right y'all let's wrap up with
something fun I found on social media
perfect for this particular hour this is
what I'm
liking so earlier today we met Lenny the
dancing doorman you saw those skills you
were jealous I know uh well just across
the pond in Dublin Ireland we discovered
another super talented gentleman Sean
the singing Dorman he often greets
Shoppers at a high-end department store
with a smile and tune and he's been
known to get nearby crowds in on the
music as well we have Sean on the line
right now what's up
Sean hi guys how are you hello from dou
Ireland how are you people you oh my
gosh I feel like I'm on the voice again
a Nile I love your
accent so Sean you're a dman and a
singer quite the talented man what when
when did you start doing that just start
singing well would you believe uh Kelly
I have three jobs I am a correctional
officer prison officer as we call him in
irand uh I'm a singer in the evening I
sing at weddings and kind of corporate
events and so on and then my third job
I'm a doorman in a luxury store called
Brown Thomas in Dublin it's a bit like
Bloomingdales in New York if that makes
sense so I'm uh I'm like Superman you
know I have these different alter egos
but instead of a but instead of a cape I
have a top hat and a suit and I
transform into this kind of singing dman
to bring a bit of joy and fun to the
people of of Dublin and Ireland in
general I love that so where does the
come in do you just is it like a holiday
thing or do you do it all the time well
I've been working with brown Thomas
which is the store for many many years
and it's kind of evolved over the years
um so you kind of stand at the door you
meet and greet the customers as as a
doorman H pose for photos with tourists
and families and so on but the bonus is
I have a front row seat to the amazing
musicians and singers who are busing on
Grafton Street and I sang with a guy
called Jacob cman lovely lovely guy he's
one of the many very talented bers in in
D and I took my hat off like this and I
sent it around and collected money and I
kind of tapped the money into his into
his guitar case and I said thanks very
much folks back to the door H and it
went viral it's the best fun you know
best fun so here's the deal okay if you
come to Dublin I look for the singing
Dorman and maybe you and I can we can do
a song together how does that sound
threaten me with
a yes I love Ireland I love Dublin and
next time I'm there you better sing with
me I'm mama's going to show up don't
invite
her thank you so much Sean I'm liking
your post right now it's the first of
the season and that's not all my man our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
the friction go to erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to celebrate
people fearlessly embracing their loves
and passions and talents just like you
so they're going to give you $1,000
how's that sound
no
oh my gosh Sean I love
you I'll see you in Dublin sir thank you
so much and thank you to all our guests
this hour Seth Myers hod copy Jen Bush
Hager Jane Kowski CJ Noel and everyone
of you in the audience working so hard
to spread happiness across this city we
are excited to be in New York y'all
thank youall for having us we're excited
to be back on the air and sharing daily
love with all of you have have a great
day and if it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home